i was also thinking in terms of the
automated expansion of the knowledge
base you mentioned nlu
this is very early days in the machine
learning space of this but
self-supervised learning methods you
know you have these language models
gpt-3 and so on they just read the
internet
and they form representations
that can then be mapped to something
useful the question is what is the
useful thing
uh like they're now playing with a
pretty cool thing called the openiac
codex which is generating programs from
documentation okay that's kind of useful
it's cool
but my question is can it be used to
generate
um in part maybe with some human
supervision
uh psych-like assertions
help feed psych more assertions from
this giant body of internet data
yes that that is in fact one of our
goals is how can we harness machine
learning how can we harness natural
language processing um to increasingly
automate
the knowledge acquisition process the
growth of psych and that's what i meant
by priming the pump that um you know if
you you sort of learn things at the
fringe of what you know already
you learn this new thing is similar to
what you know already and here are the
differences and the new things you had
to learn about it and so on so the more
you know
the more and more easily you can learn
new things but unfortunately inversely
if you don't really know anything
then it's really hard to learn anything
and so
if you're not careful if you start out
with too small
sort of a core to start this process
it never really takes off and so that's
why i view this as a pump priming
exercise to get a big enough
manually produced even though that's
kind of ugly duckling technique put in
the elbow grease to produce a large
enough core
that you will be able to do all the
kinds of things you're imagining
without without sort of ending up with
the kind of
wacky brittlenesses that we see for
example in
gpt3
where
it uh
you know you'll tell it a story about um
you know someone
putting the poison
you know plotting to poison someone and
so on and then the um you know then you
know gpt three says um what's you say
what's the very next sentence the next
sentence is oh yeah that person then
drank the poison they just put together
it's like that's probably not what
happened or someone or um if you go to
siri and um um
you know i think i have uh you know
where can i go for um help with my um
alcohol problem or something it'll come
back and say i found seven liquor stores
near you right you know and you know so
on so you know it's one of these things
where um yes it may be helpful
most of the time it may even be correct
most of the time but if it doesn't
really understand what it's saying and
if it doesn't really understand why
things are true and doesn't really
understand how the world world works
then some fraction of the time it's
going to be wrong now if your only goal
is to sort of find relevant information
like search engines do
um then being right 90 of the time is
fantastic that's unbelievably great okay
however if your goal is to like um you
know save the the life of your child who
has some medical problem or your goal is
to
be able to drive you know for the next
10 000 hours of driving without getting
into a fatal accident and so on then you
know
error rates down at the 10 percent level
or even the 1 level not really
acceptable
i like the model
of with that learning happens at the
edge and then you kind of think of
knowledge as this fear
so uh
if you want a large fear because the uh
the learning is happening on the surface
exactly so you have the the what you can
learn next increases quadratically as
the diameter of that sphere um goes up
it's nice because you think when you
know nothing
it's like you can learn anything but the
reality not really
right if you know if you know nothing
you can really learn nothing
you can appear to learn so i'll also um
one of the anecdotes i could go back and
give you about why
why i feel so strongly about this
personally
was
in
1980-81
my daughter nicole was born and she's
actually doing fine now but when she was
a baby
she was diagnosed as having meningitis
and
doctors wanted to do all these scary
things
and
my wife and i were very um worried and
we could not get a meaningful answer
from her doctors about exactly why they
believed this what the alternatives were
and so on and fortunately a friend of
mine ted shortly was another assistant
professor in computer science
at stanford at the time and
he'd been building a program called
mycin which was a medical diagnosis
program that happened to specialize
in
blood infections like meningitis and so
he had privileges at stanford hospital
because he was also an md
and so we got hold of her chart and we
put in her case and it came up with
exactly the same diagnoses and exactly
the same therapy recommendations but the
difference was because it was a
knowledge-based system a rule-based
system it was able to tell us step by
step by step
why
this was the diagnosis and step by step
why this was the best um
therapy and the best procedure to um
to do for her and so on and there was a
real epiphany because that made all the
difference in the world instead of
blindly having to trust in authority we
were able to understand what was
actually going on and
so at that at that time i realized that
that really is what was missing in
computer programs was that even if they
got things right
because they didn't really understand
the way the world works and why things
are the way they are they weren't able
to give explanations of their answer
you know and you know it's one thing to
to use a machine learning system that
says this is what you should you know i
i think you should get this operation
and you say why and it says you know
0.83 and you say no in more detail why
and it says 0.831 you know
that's not really very compelling and
that's not really very helpful
you